a scathing new report finds one of the
largest data breaches in the US history
was entirely preventable a 14-month
congressional investigation slammed
credit monitoring agency Equifax for
lacking preventative measures hackers
stole the personal information of 148
million Americans last year and it
Werner shows us how the breach put you
at risk and how you can safeguard your
data and a good morning good morning the
House Oversight Committee report says
hackers gained access to the Equifax
Network in May of last year and attacked
the company for 76 days thieves stole
sensitive information including Social
Security numbers from nearly half of US
adults and some consumer advocates want
Equifax to pay this is the credit score
after consistently going down
Kelly Kraus is identity theft nightmare
began just months after the Equifax
breach I couldn't figure out how this
could have happened as careful as I am
with my information Krause says she
discovered 12 accounts opened in her
name by people using her personal
information to buy things like a car
even charging an 800 $68 veterinary bill
for a pet she doesn't own I pictured
myself maybe not being able to get loans
in the future
having bad credit now the report from
the House Oversight Committee says the
Equifax breach was entirely preventable
Republican congressman will heard is on
the committee this breach could have
been prevented if Equifax would have
followed some very basic things when it
comes to good digital system hygiene the
96 page report says Equifax failed to
modernize its technology failed to patch
its systems when vulnerabilities were
detected and stored sensitive data on
out of date and subpar systems Equifax
told us in a statement during the few
hours we were given to conduct a
preliminary review we identified
significant inaccuracies and disagree
with many of the factual findings but
consumer advocates like Mike lit with
the US Public Interest Research Group
say the company should pay the price for
harming consumers it's really only when
there's acts
we finds attached that we're gonna see
the credit bureaus take our data
security seriously congressman Hurd says
Congress should develop a national
breach standard we should be exploring
whether there should be penalties for
companies not following some of those
very basic things well the committee
made several recommendations to prevent
future incidents like those at Equifax
including to reduce the use of Social
Security numbers as personal identifiers
and here are a few reminders of what you
can do to protect yourself freeze your
credit at the three agencies have secure
passwords we've heard that before and
hey shred your sensitive documents
beyond Anna thank you